next harvard university professor
Ricardo Hausmann questions author
William easterly about his book the
elusive quest for growth a critique of
World Bank development policies this
event from the Center for Global
Development in Washington DC is an hour
15 minutes
welcome to the Center for Global
Development welcome for the kickoff
evening of development matters
development matters is a series of books
and movie presentations that the center
will be hosting the idea is to bring
together development professionals and
policy professionals to engage in
discussion about issues quite important
to the poor in developing countries so
we hope that after this evenings
presentation you'll join us in the back
for a reception meet someone new and
talk about issues that were brought up
during the conversation and have a good
time our first speaker this evening as
you all know is William easterly bill is
truly is a senior fellow here at the
center he came to us after 16 years at
the World Bank where his research
focused on determinants of long-run
economic growth and the effectiveness of
development aid he is in fact going to
be focusing his research here at the
center on aid effectiveness this evening
he will be presenting his book which is
called the elusive quest for growth
which comes from many travels and
experiences in his work during his time
at the bank he traveled to most parts of
the developing world most extensively in
Mexico Jamaica Ghana Colombia Thailand
Russia Kenya and Pakistan not bad and
those collection of stories and
experiences have fed into the elusive
quest for growth which you'll see
tonight joining bill after he gives his
presentation we Ricardo Hausmann Ricardo
Hausmann is a professor at the Kennedy
School of Government at Harvard he is a
professor of the practice of economic
development Kieffer and how he got to
know Nancy actually was his chief
economist of the inter-american
Development Bank and previously he
served as a minister of planning in
Venezuela so we are this evening in very
good hands to have the kind of
conversation we hope to have and for
those of you that know finally Ricardo
Hausmann based on all of his experiences
he has is excellent at creating
antidotes that illustrate the
development questions that we want to
talk about tonight so first I'd like to
welcome Bill easterly and when he's
concluded then to a Ricardo Hausmann
will join him on the stage please enjoy
the evening
good evening how are you we're waiting
for the screen to come down I have two
very serious purposes tonight one is to
tell you how much they care deeply about
economic development and the potential
for bettering the lives of eighty-five
percent of humanity that live in the
poor countries the other serious purpose
is to try to get you to buy copies of my
book also known as the elusive quest for
growth now you might have wondered
during Sarah's introduction whether the
publication of this book and some of the
little controversies that surrounded it
had anything to do with my leaving the
World Bank and joining this new center
for global development that Nancy
Birdsall is heading but actually the
departing from the World Bank was very
amicable I want to make that clear some
senior vice president's the World Bank
even offered to help me pack my office
so so anything I say tonight about the
World Bank I want you to taking the
spirit of friendly friendly amicable
relationship let me start with a an
anecdote about the more serious reality
of economic development when I was
working on the book I was on a trip to
pakistan and as I as most World Bank
economist do before going to Pakistan I
I did all the research on and what were
the hard facts and numbers about
Pakistan i found out that Pakistan is
actually the world's third largest
recipient of foreign aid it's gotten
fifty eight billion dollars over the
last four decades and to receive 22
structural adjustment loans from the IMF
and World Bank and the last decade has
been undertaking the intensive eight
billion dollar social action program to
improve social services of which the
donors have put up two billion dollars
but when I actually went to Pakistan and
went out into the field I came to
villages like a little village called
Guevara that was outside of Lahore
Pakistan though as many of you know the
one of the principal cities at Pakistan
and a favored Lahore that is was a favor
death destination for foreign aid but
just going a few kilometers outside
lahore I came to this village that had
no roads where the village elders told
me they they had no doctor to turn to in
case they got sick the village elders
said that the girls of their village
looked like they were likely to join the
75% a Pakistani women that cannot read
because there was no school for girls in
the village they had no sewers or
sanitation or drainage
I visited a the home of the village
elders and they they had a family of
nine living in two small 8 by 8
windowless rooms where only source of
energy was to burn cattle dung for fuel
this was the reality after fifty eight
billion dollars of aid to Pakistan that
we still had grinding poverty in
villages not far outside the principal
city of Pakistan what are the reasons
for why aid has not delivered better
results I want to suggest that we were
led astray by five panaceas of economic
development assistance now we put our
faith in that turned out to disappoint
us the first was that that aid itself
would directly bring benevolent results
to the countries where you gave it to
her the second was that we thought
benevolent governments would deliver
good results in it enable economic
development to happen when that didn't
happen we thought that foreign agencies
like the World Bank and IMF could put
conditions on the government to make
them benevolent when that flag then we
tried various direct interventions in
two countries to try to foster economic
development and then as true economist
when all else failed returned to the
panacea of a benevolent free market to
solve all all remaining problems that
went that we're left after the first
four panaceas didn't quite pan out let
me go through these panaceas one by one
the first is the fantasy of a benevolent
aid this is based on a very simple idea
that what poor countries were laughing
with simply productive capacity they
simply lack the machines and the plants
and factories and equipment they needed
to produce a lot of output so all that
we needed to do is to get a lot of
investment in developing in poor
countries and with a lot of investment
we would enable them to take off and
reach self sustained growth well the
only problem with achieving investment
was
that the poor countries didn't have much
saving they didn't have much available
commercial financing so that left a big
financing gap to cover the necessary
investment and the role of foreign aid
was very simple to fill that big hole in
the accounts to fill the financing gap
and to enable the financing of
investment that would an intern enable
economic growth but we didn't realize
something that that I'm going to return
to again and again in the next hour and
a half I mean 20 minutes expiry we we
didn't realize something that I'm going
to return to again and again which is
that that people respond to the
incentives that they're facing and that
we we just assume that giving people a
would create the incentive for them to
invest a lot in machinery and equipment
but actually the machines in poor
countries often have a low pay off
because the workers have low skills and
because the institutions are very poor
quality so under those circumstances
there weren't the incentives to invest
to use the aid proceeds to invest and
what actually happened was that people
and governments wind up consuming the
aid proceeds instead of invest in them a
rational response but one that did not
lead to economic development now do I
could show you some statistical evidence
to to make that point but instead i'll
just show you how it worked out in one
country here's what would have happened
in zambia if things had worked out as as
our models and our theories had had
worked out as planned zambia would have
gone from an income per capita of six
hundred dollars in 1962 today being
having an income per capita twenty
thousand dollars it would be an
industrialized country Zambia would be
let's start getting invited to g8
meetings which
become the g9 with Zambia and in Zambia
would today be enjoying a beautiful
future but tragically the reality was
very different per capita income in
Zambia stagnated and actually fell since
independence because a did not go into
investment and investment did not go
into growth in Zambia so the idea that
aid would achieve miracles on its own
without the proper incentives didn't
work so next we turn to the panacea
vanilla government we thought
governments were well-intentioned and
although we needed to do is just give
them the right advice just fly in lots
of people wearing suits and ties like
Ricardo and me or wearing suits without
ties like Nancy and and just give them
the right advice and then governments
will do the right thing and get
incentives right well once again we are
wrong because we forgot about another
kind of incentives political incentives
governments in polarized societies face
the incentives to dispense a lot of
patronage to people who are in the
ruling coalition which they extract from
people who are unlucky enough to be
outside of the ruling coalition they
choose redistribution over long-run
economic development so governments are
not so benevolent as we expected to go
back to Pakistan after all that social
action that I mentioned a moment ago at
eight billion dollars of social action
Pakistan's government today is still
only spending two dollars per capita on
health of the population about enough
for a bottle of tylenol for each
Pakistani to last the whole year and
this wasn't necessarily because of a
shortage of funds because the the
previous governments not not commenting
at all as a good diplomat about the
current government the previous
governments did manage to find the money
for a 1.2 billion dollar expressway
which is used principally by the elite
to commute from Islamabad to Lahore and
from which the previous prime minister
is estimated to have gotten a ten
percent kickback
from the Korean company that built it he
is now in exile in in Saudi Arabia and I
hope not reading about this this talk
and the 11 radical Pakistani economist
put it very succinctly that the ruling
elites found it convenient to perpetuate
low literacy because the lower the
proportion of literate people the lower
the probability the ruling elite could
be displaced what makes this quote
particularly poignant is this is a
person who is actually a member of the
ruling elite this is mr. Raju Sain who
is the governor of the central bank of
pakistan even the ruling elite realizes
that that this is their motivation so
next we turn to the panacea of
benevolent conditions if governments are
not benevolent on their own when we give
them good advice maybe the IMF and the
World Bank and other development
agencies can force them to be benevolent
we could change bad governments into
good ones by imposing conditions on
loans now in a large bureaucracy i
learned in 16 years whenever you want to
do something so so bold and naked as
force someone to do something that you
want them to do you have to invent a
nice neutral sounding word for it so the
word that we came up with with
structural adjustment governments had to
do structural adjustment and this would
enable countries to achieve what we
called adjustment with growth that they
would undergo a big change in behavior
and this would foster a lot of economic
growth so the goal of the whole
structural adjustment lending was to
foster economic growth did things work
out that way well for a lot of reasons
that we can talk about later the the
lending agencies had the incentive to
disburse the funds often when the
conditions were not met or when the
governments were not really good
governments and had not really changed
or because there were political
motivations like the effects that some
countries were allies of influential
a nurse and the government's it knew
this and so they felt fairly weak
incentives to change their behavior
especially compared with those powerful
incentives we talked about a moment ago
to dispense patronage to to the elites
and two favorite ethnic groups and
regions so things didn't for as far as
adjustment with growth things did not
really work out as planned there was a
lot of adjustment lending as measured by
the number of adjustment loans and the
blue line measured on the right-hand
side access the number of adjustment
loans but unfortunately the growth of
adjusting of countries getting these
loans behaved kind of like a.com stock
and and took a steep dip in the 80s and
90s just a structural adjustment was
coming online growth was not achieved
growth was close to zero so next we turn
to another instrument where we thought
we could make governments benevolent
since the loans did not work out as
planned we had to forgive the loans that
it makes sense that since adjustment
loans were used on productively they
couldn't be paid back so the World Bank
and IMF eventually felt compelled to
agree to debt relief because the debt
could not be repaid now fortunately for
them this turned out to be kind of a
public relations coup because at the
same time as they agreed to debt relief
there was a big consensus for debt
relief that was being mobilized by such
well-known economist as the Pope the
rock star bono from the group you to the
Dalai Lama George W Bush who I was kind
of surprised to hear was in favor debt
relief I still kind of suspect he didn't
understand the question
that the globalization demonstrators and
so on mobilized a big coalition for debt
relief but once again we're having very
as as external aid agencies are finding
once again they're having a lot of
difficulty and actually achieving any
change in behavior and changing good
government bad governments into good
ones with debt relief just as with the
original loans so since the aid didn't
work since the benevolent government
didn't work since the benevolent
conditions didn't work return to the
panacea the benevolent intervention
maybe we can intervene directly as aid
agencies and donors into poor countries
and and make them rich by by some kind
of special intervention the benevolent
intervention one of my religious friends
said that we were kind of invoking our
lady of the benevolent intervention and
the kind of interventions that we had a
mind were were things like what in the
early years it was dams and roads but as
we got more sophisticated we started
talking about schools and health clinics
family planning central bank
independence currency boards which have
worked out fairly well for most
countries like Argentina democracy is
one of the latest one of the latest
magical interventions that were pushing
as donors all of these things have a
common theme that they took something
that was very a very productive
institution or object in a rich country
and tried to transfer that object to a
poor country in the hope that that
object would bring with it all the
riches and all the potential of the rich
countries but once again I ran afoul of
the problem that people respond to
incentives when you take these objects
and you place them in poor institutional
environments with bad governments then
these these interventions turn out not
to be as productive as we hoped I'll
just give you the example of Education
there was a massive expansion of
schooling in the
in the developing world but creating
skills requires more than just building
schools and and just paying teachers it
requires teachers to be high skilled in
contrast to those some of those I met at
Pakistan that were barely more qualified
than the students they were teaching it
requires a lot of parental and student
effort so the parents and students have
to feel the incentive that they will be
rewarded at a high skilled job will be
waiting for them when they graduate from
school and transferring resources
without those kind of incentives and
efforts in place doesn't actually create
growth and so i'll give you another one
of my ex diagrams other economists do
supply and demand i like to do things
that are where the effort is rising but
the payoff is falling the effort here is
shown by initial years of schooling did
actually increase a lot over the over
the decades but as i showed you already
growth did not respond just as all this
schooling was coming online the
schooling was coming online and it's
also true if we compare continents and
countries to each other it's not true
that those who expanded schools the most
were those that achieve the best results
in terms of economic growth in fact East
Asia which is is usually believed to
have relied upon schooling heavily in
attaining its it's miracle its
miraculous growth is actually the sick
the region that is the second fastest
growing in terms of human capital in
terms of schooling the first of the
region that ranks first in most rapid
expansion of education is Africa know
all too sadly Africa has not had group
to grow anything like a growth miracle
has not had growth at all despite the
massive edge expansion of education in
Africa
so as lastly as i said earlier when all
else failed returned to the benevolent
market and the theories of economists
hit actually had had a lot of held out a
lot of hope for poor countries about
what a benevolent free global a global
free market would do for the poor
countries we thought that where capital
was scarce that meant that and we
thought poor countries were poor because
capital was scarce and where capital was
scarce the standard idea of economist is
where something is scarce that should
have a high price it should have a high
return so where if capital was scarce in
poor countries and that's why they
reported capital new capital should have
very high returns it should have a big
payoff to inject capital where it so
scarce and so poor countries should
attract a lot of capital and they should
tend to catch up to the richest
countries free market capital should
want to flow from the rich countries to
the poor countries and also human
capital skills and educated people
should want to move from the rich
countries to the poor countries and that
should enable poor countries to catch up
rapidly in our wonderfully global
globalised economy well things didn't
quite work out that way so far in the
globalised economy in the 90s in the 90s
20 the richest twenty percent of the
world population which is will well
represented in this room tonight read
all of you received 92% portfolio
capital gross inflows during the 1990s
whereas the poorest twenty percent of
the world's population received just 0.1
percent a portfolio capital gross
inflows so free market capital o from
rich to poor countries also as many of
you know all too well human capital the
skilled people did not flow from rich
countries to poor countries but it was
the other way around the infamous brain
drain so for example countries that are
small countries that are near the u.s.
magnet have most of their college
graduates now living in the US countries
like Guyana Jamaica and Trinidad have
more than fifty percent of their college
graduates contributing to the
productivity of the US economy but not
contributing to the productivity of
Jamaica Guyana and trinidad and so maybe
that helps explain why over the last
half-century and it's still true over
the last two decades the poorest
countries have continued to stagnate
while the richer richest countries have
gotten richer so there's been increased
divergence between poor countries and
rich countries with a few happy
exceptions of poor countries that have
broken out of the pack and have
overtaken the rich countries but on the
whole the poorest countries have stayed
poor and divergence has increased so the
five panaceas of development assistance
that have failed us on our elusive quest
for growth where the benevolent aid the
benevolent government the benevolent
conditions the benevolent intervention
and the benevolent market even failed us
so what do we need now well I think now
we need a revolution we need something
like a new center for global development
we we need to change the way we've been
operating and find new ways of operating
that deliver better results in the past
we need to fix incentives for donors to
not just move money as they too often
have had the incentive to do but
actually direct their resources to where
they will achieve the best results we
have to figure out ways of reaching the
poor people with the participation of
the poor communities
somehow creating market incentives to
fix all the bad incentives that they
face give them subsidies give them
whatever is necessary to give them
decentralized market incentives to lift
themselves out of poverty and help
themselves but the foreign aid community
has to to think about government much
more than it much more carefully than it
has in the past not just disperse money
will it willy-nilly and unselective Lee
but but wait for really change to happen
at at home in the poor countries and
only then when there are homegrown
reform programs in the poor countries
then give then give foreign assistance
because only then is it really going to
be effective when change is led by
people within the countries is only then
will foreign assistance will be will it
be effective and if the government does
not change then we have to think of
creative ways of bypassing bad
governments when we when we still want
to try to reach the poor individuals of
those societies with bad governments but
one thing we cannot do is we cannot give
up even after all these 50 years of
effort of development assistance and of
economist studying the problems in poor
countries we can't give up on the poor
not as long as there are villages out
there like Guevera Pakistan not as long
as the girls and women of Guevera still
are being left out of economic
development so to borrow the words of a
former president of the US who is
somewhat more eloquent than the current
one let us keeps driving as development
economists and people who care about
economic development so that economic
development of the people by the people
and for the people does not perish from
the earth
good night thing good evening to all
yeah I think that we're all going to
rush rush off and go buy your book I was
Valentine's Day is coming up yeah it's
really an honor and a pleasure to to be
here to discuss builds marvelous book I
read it when it was in draft form and I
was enormously excited by it in a he's a
much much more careful thinker than his
simple graphs suggest that these these
simple associations that he has in in
those graphs are very carefully done in
the book and this is not sort of like a
annamma a dilettante a book on on
economic development this is a scholarly
book it's it is a scholar a hour a it is
scholarly and provocative which is hard
to achieve at the same time and it is
moving which is also hard to achieve and
scholarly product provocative and moving
and it still gets to be fun so so those
are I would say four attributes that
achieving it in in the context of the
book is really really a major a major
thing and i want to emphasize a word
that he stole or he probably came up on
his own with it but that i was always I
always thought was central to this whole
endeavor and that's the idea of the
quest this is the quest for Economic
Development sort of like puts you as a
development economist in a median mode
of of trying to just kill the Dragons
save the world and and there's a lot of
of that oomph in them in the in the book
so it's really really a
really a nice nice piece of work one of
the most important books I've written
last in the last few years and it's it's
really nice that this book is coming out
now that bill is at the center for
global development aim which as you know
is the not the new boy in town but the
new girl in town i guess and i want to
congratulate nancy for her leadership
and I wish her well I think that day the
world needs needs a center like this m
and it's interesting that the book comes
up with saying you know look documents
that there isn't a really really serious
failure in economic development and
after the world has tried for 50 years
to promote economic development a
document that failure is is important
and it's also difficult and it's so so
difficult a that you can see that it
causes a labor mobility so I think that
a the book also has the merit of
documenting this massive failure without
at the same time giving up so it's not a
book to say you know too difficult tough
luck so it is both serious about the
magnitude of the failure and the depth
of the failure in outcomes in policies
and in thinking and I think that it is
useful to start the discussion with with
the magnitude out of the failure in and
i would i would like to say that a there
are some very very powerful ideas in the
book that i think we should take them
for as being practical truths going
forward first one is that the secret of
growth is not about asset accumulation
that was what we all thought it was
about that if you take
the neoclassical model and so on it
would say that you know the level of
income that a country would converge to
depends on how much it saves how much it
educates a and so r accumulate machines
you accumulate years of schooling you
grow and the international community
should help countries accumulate
machines accumulate years of schooling
and they would grow and I think that the
most glaring catastrophe of of of the
development effort has been the fact
that we have been able to achieve higher
levels of schooling we have been able to
achieve increased life expectancy we
have been able to achieve reduced infant
mortality and we have not been able to
achieve higher incomes and that that is
a glaring failure that needs needs
explanation and must be that we did not
get the secret of growth right so growth
is probably not about asset accumulation
the second thing that I think the book
establishes quite well and it's an
important fact is that a capital and
human capital doesn't go from abundant
places too scarce places that there's
something that sort of makes it stick
where it's abundant and that makes all
our lives much more much harder we would
have thought that there were four if it
was true that capital would move from
where its abundant to where it scares
then something would hold the income
distribution in the world more or less
together now Bill's friend and my friend
lant pritchett had an article a few
years ago called divergence big time
that tried to document the fact that the
world was really diverging and a bill
just showed us a graph about that
divergence and I was looking at that
graph I remembered a question in my
final exam
sixth grade in my final exam in sixth
grade I was 11 years old him a move I
don't know it was a course on Venezuela
was called idle morals and civics or
something and and then and and there the
goal of the world was to narrow the gap
between the rich countries and the poor
countries and that was sort of like the
gap lebretia that was the goal we've
cannot open that the gap is increasing
by leaps and bounds it's huge we're
you're having a huge part of humanity
being left behind so that's that's an
important idea then a bill tries to
document that conditionality doesn't
work and here the idea is that you
cannot force governments to do what they
don't want to do and that if they just
followed what no we wrote in though in
the loan a then the loan would have
worked well but it's because they did
not follow what was in the loan that
things did not turn out as expected here
I'm and it's not that I disagree with
the idea here I think that it it is not
because they did follow or did not
follow what was in the loan bill could
even argue and he doesn't he didn't but
he could argue that had they followed
what was in the loan probably it
wouldn't have paid off either it's not
it's not because necessarily the
government's did not do what we told
them I think that you can document that
in many cases when governments have done
what we thought not what we thought what
we told him what everybody thought was
the right thing to do the payoff was not
as expected
so my main point my main critique or my
main attempt to get the bill excited
enough to fight with me is is that I
think it bill sees the world too much
from Washington and the question he asks
is he wants in essence he wants aid to
be successful and he's frustrated at the
fact that aid has not been successful
he's frustrated at the fact that
governments do not do what is right and
he's frustrated at the fact that the
international community cannot force
them to do what is right but he is
trying to work this problem out from
Washington now thank God the World Bank
is helping change this paradigm he'll
have to change the world through some
other instruments and to tell you the
truth I think goal Vera is a good
example of many things but it's not
really the best example of the failure
because go Vera is not a possible if you
don't do anything you don't get anything
it's not that big of a puzzle the really
big puzzle about development as being
that governments relatively serious
decent governments relatively serious
decent politicians relatively well
working political systems have done a
lot of what we thought would work out a
they did educate girls in Latin America
the average years of schooling of women
aged 18 to 22 is on average higher than
men they did provide health and sewage
and phone systems and infrastructure and
so on they did really try this mix of
assuring economic openness together with
better governance if you took take all
the indices of quality of government
democracy regulatory performance they
all have improved and the outcome has
been remarkably disappointing as build
documents in the last 25 years the
average rate of per capita income growth
by country not not weight by population
but waived by the number of countries
has been zero while the average rate of
growth a of income per capita and the
industrial world over the last 25 years
has been about fifty percent so that's
more or less the widening of the gap
that he that he showed but I wouldn't
attributed attributed at least in the
part of the world I known to
government's not being better than they
used to be policies not being more like
the ones we think would succeed but the
but the payoff has not been there in my
part of the world since 1998 the region
latin america has not grown this year is
going to be the pits and there's no no
expected big payoff and in fact we have
pretty much ran out of ideas of how to
fix the world so i would like to finish
saying with a question to build in
assume you're a minister not a
protestant minister okay a what would
you do differently from what would be
the current mantra of assuring economic
openness good working markets and good
governance
okay so as to sort of like get the
economic incentives at least from that
back through that mechanism right a-and
and see sit back and see see growth
growth follow is there anything that you
think a government should do that is not
what everybody today things that they
should be doing it seems like a good
time to open the floor for questions
well I I first of all thanks regard
though for those generous generous
remarks and thought thoughtful remarks I
I agree with a lot of what you're saying
that that governments have done some of
the things now especially those in Latin
America that that we thought was quote
good behavior they have improved macro
policies and so on but we now realize
that there are a lot of other dimensions
besides just getting macro that now we
could add a six panacea they're getting
macro policies right is not is not good
enough to foster economic growth and
there there are deeper roots 22 under
development to use the old-fashioned
word that have to do with how how much
feedback there is from local communities
to their governments how accountable the
government's are to local communities
how effective they are actually
delivering what the people want
delivering the services that people want
how honest the official government
officials are at all all levels these
are all things that unfortunately only
approve improve gradually over time so
there is no quick fix these are things
that were very bad in the countries that
are now rich like the US
and have gotten a lot better and have
fostered prosperity as they've gotten a
lot better so those are those kind of
what are often called second-generation
issues of because the first generation
was didn't didn't pass the exam the
second generation is is being asked to
to fill fill the breach of a much deeper
change in society in which governments
will be accountable to a majority of the
population to really deliver what they
want and not just be captured by elites
not just be engines of patronage and
redistribution max
as I mexico from sighs Johns Hopkins and
makes suggestion you've written a great
book I don't agree that at all but it
should be really vol 1 of a trilogy no
vol 2 and I want to well if a man is
case studies of success stories now
there have been success stories in terms
of population singer poured one end the
people's republic of china under things
out team at the other right malaysia
thailand and episodes brazil periods of
hydro society i think it's worth
studying that in depth and i consider
indonesia to be a great success story
other than the last four year but if you
take a longer view since nineteen
sixty-five it's had a tremendous success
they may aid may have played a very
small part in it but of course what did
indonesia had is oil money which is
equivalent of unconditional a and in
this case for reasons that we're
studying they use it reasonably well i'm
not saying there isn't corruption and
it's not democracy and so the fact is in
terms of measured gdp per capita which
is a successor return a large number of
people and even China even more when
incidentally you mentioned that figures
about comparing poor and rich countries
waiting by number of countries just
picked it up I mean effort to have lots
of God rests with China is just one
country India is just one color so in
terms of weight and so on I think we
should take a close look at China and
India and chai India actually has now in
the this frickin some period has had an
improvement nothing is we're studying
that just look at success stories and
what lessons going to remind you also
there are some European countries that
were once considered underdeveloped
including of this one Spain and within
my lifetime not yours Portugal Greece
and you know it's dark people have been
successful so I think study there
and the third and the trilogy with
having studied the failures which is
what you've written a book about and the
successes the third trilogy in the
volume is what can be done at the margin
to improve things not necessary to
transform Chad into Korea but just to
make things a bit better and chat and
can it be done to some extent with
outside a door not the practical volume
so those three volumes you would have
fully justified your time here to set up
oh thank thank you max for reminding us
that there are a lot there are some
successes there is hope and further work
at the usual conclusion and economics
that further work is needed Aggie I'm
Gabe pfefferman i'm at the ifc at the
moment but I've spent my entire
professional life in the eighth business
so my heart goes out to tur bill also
bought his book I have a very small
suggestion and which I want to about the
aid and transferring resources those of
you who have read the Atlantic review
this this current issue there's a small
snippet by James fellows in there about
something called development space.com
and bill is not the only person who's
illustrates labor market movements there
is Whittle and Mary Qureshi who our
colleague former colleagues of his of
the word Bank created at the time when
the dot-coms were tanking a little calm
called development space.com what this
is is it does a way it's a way to put
people want to give money together with
people with projects with a certain
degree of scrutiny based on character
and like eBay building up a reputation
that does away with two things at least
which have crippled the eight business
one is the principal agency issue
because here you put
directly the guy who once a woman wants
to get money together was the person
wants to build a school and Chad and
secondly it reduces transaction costs
and think that one of the things that is
absurd in the eighth business is the
costs of delivering a dollar to chart I
mean it's just preposterous so they have
a better website hewlett-packard is part
of this so it's a public-private
partnership they put their lifetime
savings in this I mean they're trying to
make a go of this India is going to be
the first window the first test case and
if this works and it's a very small seed
if this works five ten years from now
there might be a window not just for
grants but also for equity investments
and loans and who knows this made this
intimate this inter mediate with a
horrible world yes thank you feel free
to chime in whenever you want to I'm I'm
an admirer of I know I know Dennis
widdle and Mary Qureshi and I'm admirer
what they're doing I think there's
something there's a big idea there which
is that what we've been trying to do for
so long has been a kind of form of
Soviet central planning in the foreign
aid business and we need somehow to find
something that's much more decentralized
and like a market in which in which we
can match much more efficiently the many
people who want to give and the many
people who need and want to take their
own initiative to make their lives
better Paul
I'll bluestein it with Washington Post
build those people who offered so
graciously to pack your stuff and bring
it over here for you I have a Heather
have this new panacea that they call
empowerment that's the big buzzword at
the World Bank these days and I'd like
you to comment on that you seem to be
suggesting that and you're maybe the in
your response to Ricardo but you know
that maybe there was something to this
that may know making governments
accountable and giving the poor voice
and so forth was essential so perhaps
you were not quite as cynical about that
as as about about the pendency of
empowerment as some of the other
panaceas and I'd like to couple this
with a question um that I've been sort
of puzzling over as I particularly when
I look at your example of Pakistan and
you as you know I've read your paper
about particular about Pakistan and been
there myself and look and seen the
terrible problem of you know corrupt
civil service and and lack of them total
lack of empowerment of the poor in an
almost medieval sense that makes pouring
money into that country such as you know
such a sieve sort of outcome but I'm
still confused by why the same isn't
true of China because China is no
Paragon of of empowerment or
accountability or lack of corruption or
some of these other problems that I see
Pakistan like within it so say I mean is
empowerment really the the panacea and
can you explain why I mean if
empowerment or something like it is that
why is there's this vast difference
between Pakistan and China
alum let me answer the first question
about the World Bank's approach to
empowerment and leave the question on
China for Ricardo a definitely
empowerment is as part of the solution
it's kind of a horrible bureaucratic
word but it's the idea of letting poor
people get bit much more control over
their own destinies and and having
giving a lot more feedback on what they
want a need and what is working for them
and what is not working for them that's
that's definitely got to be part of the
solution or it is kind of there is a
kind of paradox about a large
bureaucratic organization coming to the
people and saying you know you will be
empowered and if you don't write your
empowerment strategy then we will write
it for you so it's it's not easy to do
from the top down you know it really has
to it really has to come a lot more from
the bottom up that is it's not going to
be an easy thing to implement from from
way on high in Washington it's as
Ricardo rightly criticized me for
thinking too much from Washington that's
not an easy thing to achieve from
Washington to empower people regard now
I mean let me be a little bit more
challenging because in we have a list of
things that we think are good and
empowerment democracy stuff right and
then a we think that and we are
disappointed about the world so our
assumption is that it is because there
is not enough of these good things that
the world is in trouble and I think that
the book contains a bunch of examples of
why many of the things that we think are
good might not be that good or might not
actually work out
phil has a beautiful example of a a
Bangladeshi company you remind me the
name of textile company dash garments
dash car dash dash dash Coruscant and in
foot with that shows that you know
somebody comes up with an idea to create
a firm the moment they realize it's
successful the general manager leaves
and sets up shop at another place and
you have a huge expansion of the
activity in that sector that to me is an
example of one of the challenges of
development which is that countries
could be producing a lot of stuff they
don't know what and finding out what it
is that they could produce is very
costly and very risky and the moment
they somebody finds out that something
can be bruised they copy him so there
are very few incentives for people to
actually find out what can be produced
and that's why the typical
characteristic of a developing country
is that I keep on producing the same
thing forever and ever they never find
out the new things that they could be
producing now it's not at all obvious to
me that opening markets and improving
governance is it does it does something
for that problem in the industrial
countries the equivalent problem is
addressed through patents and stuff
indian does in the developing world
there is nothing to assure that there
will be adequate incentives for people
to actually figure out a what can can be
produced among the things that nobody is
producing right now so it may be that we
don't have the right policy mix and then
i'm thinking you know what is the
problem in haiti right now the
international community is pulling the
plug on haiti now if you look at what
happened in haiti the marines went down
there because it was a dictator and said
you're not allowed to have dictatorship
you need democracy and so they set up a
democracy it's not working out the
government is not doing
well so until you fix your democracy we
leave I think that it is troubling it is
troubling we thought that democracy as
you mentioned one of the things that can
be transported from one place to the
other a if it works here it must work
for them interesting point I mentioned
because of the case of the traditional
comparison between India and China that
India's a democracy China is in no sense
of the word democracy and and up to
recently if the last 20 years were more
successful in China than they were in
India there was more human capital
accumulation in China and there was an
Indian so on so I think that these are
troubling questions I don't think that
you know we at the problem in the world
is that we know what is good and there's
not enough of it it may be that we have
to think harder about about these issues
and that we some of the things but that
we think are bad me or some of the
things that we need are not things that
are in the list of the good things that
we have right now I'm Peter got earlier
also X World Bank currently teaching at
sighs and have shown the Kennedy School
we haven't met yet my question I think
will echo some of the comments that have
been made I think in essence what I want
to ask you bill is imagine yourself in a
donor position not just in a minister
position that Ricardo suggested then
what would you do differently I
tremendously must say that at first
enjoyed reading your book I've spent my
whole most my entire career working on
and in developing countries so a lot of
wisdom in there and i hope you write at
second volume that mex Gordon
recommended I like the particular
chapter 8 which I think frames a new way
of thinking
about grocery better formulator than
I've seen before what I found the less
satisfying of your chapters was chapter
six where you deal with the question by
eight has it failed and what should be
done in order to make aids responsive to
incentives and you also recommend that
the donor should not give eight unless
there is a good track record of
performance and good policies now my
question to you is imagine yourself in
the position of a donor how do you deal
with that in practice it is conceptually
very attractive and I have no difficulty
Reserve and in reality is not always
that easy I mean the IMF was after all
created for emergencies and you can't
tell any an agency like that to wait for
a good track record before it can come
into business the world bank came into
the business of the structural
adjustment law of vector essentially
busty because the IMF had to be
supplemented in the early 80s we
couldn't have waited for much longer
along the lines you suggested good
policies that sounds attractive also but
isn't always easy to tell what good
policies iron when you can tell then
policies are good the many situations in
which serious economy is completely
disagree on what's good and what's not
good now you let me give the example of
Russia China again China's be mentioned
before I think most Washington economy
is thought that the policies followed by
Russia in the early nineties where the
right policies and you implicitly blame
in your book the failure of Russia on
the failure of the donors to come
forward with the money in a timely
manner well I disagree with that I think
the policies were not good policies and
out the donors did not decline the money
for it for my reasons but i think the
russian policies were completely
premature privatization and many other
things went wrong so I I think one can
seriously question how easy it is to
agree on what is good policy
take China would we have thought that t
dang reforms in the early 80s were good
policies they deliberately went for
distorting dual markets they encouraged
the establishment of millions of firms
without worrying about the different
definition of ownership rights and it
but boomed very few Western economies
would have thought that those were good
policies for China right so that's why
my challenge to you now you might still
say all right let's not agree on what is
good example but look at it xpost
already defined performance but when do
you measure performance I mean Indonesia
was a model up till January 97 right
even even Argentina we were applauding
until a year ago right so when do you
when do you feel satisfied that you can
say these are good results so I want to
challenge you on the practicality of
your recommendations in chapter 6 yes
definitely Bill Cosby not the actor
obviously from technoServe in Washington
wanted to to thank you for a wonderful
review of your thoughts on one
development and a failure and I agree
with much of your hypothesis regarding
the failures of the four of the five
fantasy is anyway but I'd like you to
comment a little bit further on the
notion of the failure of market linkages
or the market I'm not so sure that I or
I think it might be too early to
conclude that in fact markets have Dale
I specifically cover Africans been a
significant amount of time in Africa
where you have the recent creation of
many stock exchanges that have given
rise to substantial foreign direct
investment flows and it provided a means
for even you know some former I or
Africans formerly
living in Africa to invest back in
Africa so I'd like you to comment a
little bit further about the notion of
it possibly being too premature to
conclude that markets have failed Thank
answer question okay sarah says i should
answer these questions these difficult
questions but Peter Peters eloquent
question and comment illustrates the
difference being on the actually I
under-fire delivering loans as he was
versus being in the cozy confines at the
research department the World Bank as I
was all these years the it is it is
extremely hard to to make these calls
and practice we we need a lot of
humility first of all that we we don't
know what is the exact right thing to do
we don't know who's doing things exactly
right or exactly wrong however having
said that the the idea the track record
I think it does need to be much more
strongly strongly emphasized in in donor
behavior because this idea of the
emergency bailout has been used so many
times so often and repeatedly in the
same countries I mean to Ricardo mention
Haiti a while ago a haiti was bailed out
22 different times by the IMF over a
twenty two year period now when when IMF
is going back over and over again to the
same country every year with an
emergency bailout it's like it's sort of
like you know you're calling 911 your
routine health care you know it's a it's
not it's it's not the way things should
be done somehow you need a better a
better way to be selective and in real
and at some point realized that
countries like you know Ecuador which
has never completed an IMF program
and yet it still gets a new IMF program
every every other year some some point
the IMF and World Bank need to stand
back and say you know until you
establish a better track record of
delivering on your promises then then
doing our assistance should not be
forthcoming and if if we need to help
the people who are suffering under that
regime then let's help them directly but
not give money to the government that
keeps misbehaving and and probably
directing money not to the poor but to
the to the well-off markets I I I
agreeably that we don't we certainly
don't want to make any blanket statement
that markets have failed in general that
that free markets are a failure but
certainly the the historical record and
the current experiences especially over
the last two decades suggested that
markets by themselves are not a panacea
that poor countries seem to face a lot
of inherent disadvantages that there are
poverty traps that they get stuck in and
just showering free markets on them it
does not seem to be enough to get them
out of out of those poverty traps and
I'm afraid that the hopeful stories you
gave about Africa have I in my time at
the World Bank I heard those kind of
stories many times over the past 20
years and and it's still Africa kept
failing to deliver the to turn the
corner that we hoped as sympathetic
external observers that we kept hoping
it would so it's a little too soon to
say that markets have come to the rescue
of Africa it looks more like Africa is
still stuck in the poverty trap do you
want to edit
thanks so much for your presentation
bill and congratulations to you Nancy
for opening up the center my name is
Samir dasani I'm with globalization
challenge initiative just a couple of
things I wanted to say first of all
thank you Ricardo for I think rightfully
critiquing bill a little bit about on
his uh I think I think often we we tend
to blame governments too easily I think
we throw on we call get them corrupt and
all the rest of it forgetting that you
know we have a selected president and
all these kind of things problems here
ourselves and just a couple of issues
that I'd want to sort of get your
comments on one is sort of what is the
role of the private sector and all this
I mean when you when you're thinking
about corrupt governments they're not
too many governments that I can think up
there are more corrupt than say Mobutu's
a year and he was a I mean he got I
think four billion dollars in IMF loans
in 1980s alone and now there's a
government in the Democratic Republic of
Congo who you know who want to increase
the tariffs on the on the diamond the
multinational diamond companies and as a
result they're really unable they're
coming here they're begging I met with
them a few few months ago they're
begging the IMF for a loan and they're
really unable to make headway because
they want to you know they want to
negotiate for a better deal with the
diamond traders pretty much that's one
example the other example I'll give you
is the Mexican PRI which basically was
able to stay in power because they
supported us oil interests I mean it's
not too much of a secret um so the
question is what is the first of all
what is the private sector have to do
when this analysis the other thing that
I wanted to mention was when we're
thinking about what causes growth it
might be a good idea to look at the
industrialized world the United States
Britain Europe and think about how they
actually industrialized I'm not talking
about the rhetoric and these kind of
things but how do they actually
industrializing the United States
actually got out of the depression
through massive state spending and
massive protectionism which is still
there i mean this is all kind of debates
that we all know about between the
European Union and the United States
over various kind of protections but
protectionist measures that are there
right now and these are things that
these are issues that I think in your
time with the center I think you're
you're you're going to be skirting
around these issues
you're gonna have to we're gonna have to
take a strong look at them and sort of
decide well you know how did these how
did how'd it be industrialized world
industrialize well it might have been
through state spending and protectionism
and what do we do with that i'm jim fox
answer the question you know I I think
there are there are a lot of debates on
whether sort of ultra free trade is
really the the universal prescription
that you should be recommended under
every in all cases for for economic
development and protectionism should
always be ruled out I I don't think one
can take such a universalist position
and certainly it's true the u.s. used
protectionist measures at some point but
there are there are degrees of
interference with markets no it's not
all black and white think of what we
have found out from bitter experience in
the developing countries is that
protectionist measures that are
implemented bye bye week governments
with weak civil societies to monitor
them often wind up being captured by
special interests they're not you know
the whole infant industry argument just
goes out the window because it's really
just some special interest that is
captured that are capturing the the
revenues from the protection and it's
not really helping to foster industrial
development and that that degree of
interference in with markets in a in a
week society with a weak government just
does not work in practice now a modest
measure to raise a few some tax revenues
from diamonds that there's nothing
nothing obviously wrong with that I
don't I'm not in on that debate so I
I'm not sure why why that's such a
problem but but kind of sweeping
protectionism also sweeping government
government spending expansions and works
for Public Works programs those are the
those might work when you're in a
depression caused by by very low
domestic demand but a lot of excess
capacity supply available to you that
you can that you can use if you if only
you pump up demand a little bit it's
kind of ironic that the best best
implementers of this advice tend to be
conservative Republican presidents who
are always trying to get us out of
recession by spending huge amounts of
money on defense but but the the
situation is very different in most poor
countries it's not really insufficient
demand that's keeping their keeping them
so poor it's really that the productive
capacity is not there so just expanding
government and public works to try to
stimulate demand is not going to lead to
long-run growth it's really going to to
just to just exacerbate macro economic
problems without solving the more
fundamental problems of increasing
productive capacity and supply yep
I mean they're not the same time China
and India are being trumpeted in the new
world bank report as as indicating the
thing the Verger this the success that
can come from free market pro trade
policy so uh one of you is wrong why
don't you both pose your questions
together and then they can respond to
okay I I also thought it was a wonderful
book I think it really gets it a lot of
core issues at the same time I think
it's far too pessimistic about the way
the world is that the basis for judging
development is not happening is GDP
growth yet if you look at literacy rates
and compare developed countries with
developing country literacy rates you
get convergence if you look at life
expectancy you see the same trend of
considerable convergence if you look at
you know nutrition indicators or per
capita calorie intake you get the same
kind of convergence that over the last
50 years the developing countries are
catching up substantially on all of
these non GNP indicators and I think
there is there are important things
happening that are not captured by
trying to just use gdp growth
a Peter thorman formerly USAID first of
all i think is regards one objective it
doesn't sound like you're going to be
very successful namely getting a lot of
copies of your books souls and virtual a
lot of people's about it and second
already ah the comment i wanted to make
you frame the discussion in terms of a
panacea and my experience over 30 years
or so says it may not be out there and
i'd like you to comment on that i just
add to that that there been a lot of
good investments in infrastructure i
just spent a lot of time in Thailand
India we helped build the IIITs the
Indian Institutes of Technology and that
educational investment has had a lot of
returns to it not perhaps at the time
those Institute's were founded but over
time when the economy opened up those
things had an impact similarly some of
the infrastructure in Thailand had an
impact so the question to you is a you
out there looking for a panacea or is it
is it the sort of should we be
continuing the kinds of modest
investments little agencies like a ID
make thanks
it's a loaded question no no there
certainly we we should not look for
panaceas we should reorient ourselves to
away from quick fixes and and more
towards kind of slogging along making
slow progress on a number of different
dimensions and certainly there have been
some successes on some of these
dimensions like the one the first
question are mentioned and in health and
literacy and there you know the what
what we're talking about here is sort of
the average record around the average
record there have been some successful
investments that paid off and there have
been some investments there were
miserable failures the average was not a
very good result but there were some
successes hidden behind those averages
so as Max said at the beginning we could
hopefully learn more from the successes
as to what works so that development of
the people by the people and for the
people does not perish from the earth
well thank you very much
thanks also to all of you who engaged
film Ricardo and thought and discussion
I want to just let you know that the
next couple development matters programs
will be films the films that we will
host will actually be held at the
visions movie theater you will receive
announcements about this if you're not
already on the mailing list and did not
receive an invitation for this evening
please make sure that you sign up or
drop your business card on the way out
so you get future announcements about
our events right now I hope you'll Joan
join us for a few minutes for a
reception the idea is to come together
and talk a bit more informally as well
meet new people and we've got some
beverages and snacks in the back so have
a nice evening and i'll see you in
February at the next develop matters
pretty good thanks for all the nice
words
William easterly is a senior fellow at
both the Center for Global Development
and the Institute for International
Economics the elusive quest for growth
is his third book it's published by MIT
press if you'd like to find out more you
can visit their website MIT press dot
MIT done